this is a packet and bottle of
freeze-dried urine and the United States
government will sell it to you for nine
hundred and eighty three dollars plus
shipping which is perhaps the strangest
sentence I've ever start a video with
but it's true and what's even stranger
is that that's a pretty reasonable price
these are two of more than a thousand
standard reference materials that are
kept here at the National Institute of
Standards and Technology here at nurse
we produce standard reference materials
or SRMs for short as serums are super
characterized materials that our
customers use to make sure their
measurements on their materials and
processes are accurate and reliable when
a customer buys one of our restaurants
they get both a unit of material and a
certificate of analysis each property
whether it's chemical constituent or a
physical characteristic of the material
is a certified property and its measured
most accurately the certificate of
analysis is just as important as the
material itself without the certificate
and all the information that's inside of
it the SRM is just another bottle of
stuff we have a variety of food
materials in our SRM catalog so this is
slurry spinach when you slurry the
spinach it's nice and homogeneous so you
sample a little bit from the top it's
the same as sampling from the bottom we
also have our infamous domestic sludge
from waste water treatment process that
has been dried ground up homogenized
into this nice fine powder we take this
material we certify various toxic
elements within the sludge that's uh
what it's used for we also have the
microspheres slide that contains of the
space beads they're ten micron wide
polystyrene spheres that were formed on
the Space Shuttle in zero-gravity we
have to store some of our more sensitive
materials and cryo cooled conditions we
have our peanut butter right there in a
glass jar whose crackling and then we
have our whale blubber organics and
whale blubber
this is actually whale blubber tissue
from a beached whale it's for tracking
organic contaminants in the environment
and whales are they the end of the food
chain every one of these reference
materials has to be exactly the same to
an incredibly precise margin they'll be
used by people around the world to
calibrate and test machinery now other
places make reference materials too it's
just that everything in this warehouse
has the US government stamp of approval
on it now just to be clear the vast
majority of reference materials here are
pretty dull but they're for industrial
processes so they are metal or Dorris or
pure elements there are three types of
bauxite from Suriname Jamaica or the
Dominican Republic
there's even really precise mixes of
gases available along with some
radioactive elements sometimes it takes
us years to actually secure a new
material that becomes an SRM a couple
years later we buy industrial products
directly it comes from a different
source each time we make it but we make
it the same way and we characterize it
in the same fashion either we determine
the chemical composition or its physical
characteristics but we do that with
accuracy in other cases we have SRM that
are used to determine how they break we
measure over and over again with
different methods to ensure that what
we're measuring is the true value in
that particular material the material
itself is not precise the measurements
that characterize it are precise so if
you haven't worked it out yet the reason
that freeze-dried urine is one of the
reference materials is because there are
folks out there with machines that test
urine
they're either testing for drugs so are
the Institute will sell you urine laced
with exact amounts of the metabolites of
cannabis or cocaine or they're testing
for poisons and toxic elements so if you
need to calibrate one of those testing
machines to make sure that the results
are accurate then the folks here are the
ones you're gonna call thank you to
everyone here at the National Institute
of Standards and Technology pull down
the description for more about standard
reference materials and about their work